Entertainment Tonight presents ET Vault
unlocked Tom Hanks Entertainment Tonight
has been been part of the American
household for more than 30 years well
it's been 43 years to be exact and we've
been with Tom for all of them you should
have seen me in some younger days when
we first met the young actor on the set
of his breakout TV role it's been said
of you that you actually have great
comedy timing is this true yes and his
transformation to time Oscar winner you
really do kind of just think H how did I
get here et's never before seen
interviews with the nicest guy in
Hollywood now I know why me cuz I work
so damn hard that's why get ready for et
Vault unlocked Tom Hanks this is the
Bible of Show
Business Tom's films iconic his movie
lines legendary and clearly the man has
good taste and entertainment shows
welcome to ET our vault would not be
complete without Tom so we are tipping
our hat to the star dubbed the nicest
guy in
Hollywood hello hey how are
you you
[Music]
go you scared me people really really
really really like you Tom hack really
really really really really really
like really really really
Mr Tom
H this is all kind of a fluke in a lot
of ways that that uh have turned into
something that I'm really proud of and
work real hard to to attain and and
sustain I still feel as though I can't
believe they're giving me this job
humble genuine and somehow still
relatable et's been with Tom for five
Decades of his legendary career as a kid
growing up they said someday you're
going to be on ET I well maybe
[Music]
[Applause]
once despite two consecutive Oscars plus
four nods five Golden Globes seven emys
and an estimated net worth of $400
million I'm just a I'm an average Joe
but Tom's filmography is anything but
average he's raed in over 10 billion at
the global box office and he's behind
some of the most iconic movie lines of
our time life was like a box of
chocolates there's no crying in baseball
wion wion you do have to get used to to
people telling you that you're the
greatest thing since sliced cheese
because you know that you're still only
sliced cheese you know so it's uh you
can't believe what anybody says you
always have to come back to that same
truth am I doing the right thing before
he made it big and show biz Tom was just
a kid growing up in the Bay area of
California in Concord just outside
Oakland how old were you when when your
folks broke up five I was five I grew up
I grew up with my dad and I saw my mom
all the time there was one time when my
brother and my father and I shared the
same bedroom but uh dad had the top bunk
and my brother had the the bottom bunk
and I I had my own bed and we've never
thought that we came from a particularly
broken home we thought we came from a
very exciting home as a matter of fact
uh my my dad always uh uh gave us as as
much credibility and leeway as we wanted
because we always found our own way he
if if we were happy and we weren't
getting into any trouble and you know we
enjoyed what we were doing I he he
thought we were doing great when Tom was
a teen he did what Most teens do he
worked summer jobs while he finished
school uh I was a vendor at Oakland Aid
game oh really yeah I was 14 years old
uh first of all I got robbed twice great
the first job that I actually really
loved was was uh I was a Bellman I got
to wear a suit and I got to meet a lot
of famous people uh Sydney potier I
drove to the airport I carried sher's
bags when she was married to Greg almond
Bill Lean on Me Withers Billy Jean King
I I actually delivered bags to Chrissy
ever's room when she was in the shower
she had to come out of the shower to
open the door and did she have on a
towel she had on a towel after studying
theater in college he landed his first
acting job which whisked him all the way
from California to Cleveland Cleveland
why Cleveland first time I got union
scale to be an actor that was an amazing
thing
$216 I can said I can live on this for
for a couple of weeks of course I was on
unemployment so I'd like to thank the
taxpayers of the United States of
America for making it possible we don't
mind after 3 years Tom left the theater
to make his big screen debut in the
lowbudget slasher film he knows you're
alone then In 1980 this crossdressing
sitcom made him a star on network TV I
knew this wasn't going to work it's been
said of you that you actually have great
uh comedy timing is this true
yes are you actually tall no but
standing next to you it it is it appears
to be the case uhhuh uhhuh it's an
optical illusion I see though it only
lasted two seasons buos and buddies led
to a guest appearance on Happy Days in
1982 that's where Tom met the man who'd
cast him in the surprise hit Splash
future Oscar winner Ron Howard I mean
this was a movie about a mermaid being
made by Disney that was directed by Opie
Cunningham I mean in all in all
seriousness people were not all that
thrilled and instead it comes out and it
enters the national Consciousness
hello do you have any idea how I I got
here between 1984 in 1987 Tom was busier
than ever starring in seven more feature
films with comedy Kings like Jackie
Gleason John Candy and Dan acoid I'm
I've known I've been a funny guy for a
long time the praise for Tom reached New
Heights in 198 88 with big and can you
believe the role almost went to this guy
yep Robert dairo was in but dropped out
due to a scheduling
conflict honey the film established Tom
as a box office favorite and earned him
his first Oscar nomination it was a
surprise and a real thrill it was an
honor we were both on the couch in the
morning there kind of blubbering before
we had to go to
work as the 80s came to a close Tom's
climbed to the A-list continue thanks in
part to Meg Ryan the two played love
interests in three different films the
first Joe Versus the Volcano ET was
behind the scenes Rong coming marks and
action take me to the volcano Joe Meg
Ryan she raised the stakes of this thing
the very first day like she kicked my
butt into this all kind of other gear
just you know from one actor to another
the door to the universe is you me Meg
reportedly beat out Julia Roberts who
auditioned for the role just one week
before she got a call back for Pretty
Woman the CT classic open to mix reviews
but Tom and Meg would team up a second
time in Sleepless in Seattle about a
widowed man who finds love through the
radio who hasn't seen somebody in kind
ofone boing at at the very sight there's
no such thing as a
perfect I like the whole idea of to
parallel lives and you know these people
are meant for each other but will they
get together won't they get together and
I think that that's sort of a universal
feeling of hope that people have there
is that person that is out there that is
destined for you and you probably
crossed paths at some point in your
lives but not each other they were both
married Meg to Dennis Quaid and Tom
tarita Wilson during their lucrative run
Sleepless in Seattle and you've got mail
are still among the highest earning
romcoms of all time ranking in a
collective box office Hall over a half
billion dollars welcome
welcome Meg and I are not real close
Pals we see each other every now and
again it's like a uh we don't hang out
for C we're not like Lucy and Ethel you
know who are always Hey kid what are you
doing when we pick up we just pick up
right where we left off and it is an
effortless kind of
thing while Tom's proven he can do right
comc coms he is also a master of
onscreen Transformations ball players I
haven't got ball players I've got girls
I to be sort of aot in
this a lot an o a boore a dissipated
drunken so I usually have to come in and
be you know unleash this kind of charm
Monster that I carry along in my in a
cage wherever I go and and be likable
and witty instead I got to be everything
that they never ever let me do with
ET was on the A League of Their Own set
with Tom in Evansville Indiana back in
1991 he packed on about 30 lbs to play
boozy baseball manager Jimmy Dugan I ate
a lot of barbecued pork uh ribs and we
made our trips to the Dairy Queen what
was the toughest thing about this this
job for you shooting the whole movie uh
taking the weight off when it was all
over that was that was hard I got fat I
got fat but Tom managed to shed the
weight Plus 26 extra pounds for his
dramatic turn in 1993's Philadelphia are
you a good lawyer
Andrew I'm an excellent lawyer they put
me on a very very specific diet regimen
and exercise program for four or five
months um every day was they've brought
me my food and if I hadn't been say
quite so heavy from still from the
League of Their Own era I might might
not have had to work so hard but uh that
that's that's what Duty called for I had
no hair that shaved my head for the wigs
and and all the different looks that
we'd had to have his transformation into
Andrew Becket a gay lawyer diagnosed
with AIDS was more than skin deep and
the Oscar goes
to Tom Hanks in Philadelphia I know that
that I'm standing there honestly because
so many gay men have died of AIDS since
1976 all we're doing is throwing light
on the injustices that are going on
right now good God we need more of that
in the movies one year later Tom became
the second actor in history to win
backto back picking up the lead actor
Oscar for forced Gump that's all I have
to say about
that Houston we have a problem Tom's
also taken on many real life roles
channeling Jim level in Apollo 13
Captain Sully sullenberger even Mr
Rogers won't you be my neighbor but one
of the most extreme roles was cast away
he had to cut weight again more than 50
lbs and the pressure was intense it's
tough to do drive-thru with the kids
though you know cuz the the car is
filled with you know smell of
cheeseburgers and french fries that's
right no crispy creams an easy thing to
get
through howdy my name is Woody and this
is Andy's room that's all I want to say
got I've heard all these actors oh it's
fun it's great could you just get to
play and it's the hardest work I've ever
done as an actor it's horrible you think
acting in you know you're driving home
from space is tough to do try to sit
there and pretend to be a talking puppet
for 6 hours this is Andy we're talking
about Woody is so volatile he yells a
lot you glow in the dark my vocal cords
would be in shreds after a while I made
movies where I'd carried guys through
the jungle you know for weeks at a time
and I've never been as tired as I am
right now hey what did I tell you
earlier no one is getting replaced if I
was going to be put in a real life
version of this movie I'd be Woody
there's no question about it 27
animators and 61 other filmmakers
agonized over the tale of lost toys for
4 years before it was finally released
in theaters it kicked off a $3 billion
plus franchise that sold more than 9
billion more in merch it is a profoundly
moving and special
experience every time I've just slapped
my head and said I can't believe I'm a
part of this the Toy Story Saga will
continue with a fifth installment in
development now but of course Woody and
the rest of the gang will always have a
home at the Happ place on Earth we were
at
Disneyland and there was Buzz and Woody
as well and my daughter who was in her
30s burst into tears because she
realized that some version of her dad is
going to be at Disneyland for the rest
of Eternity that's a powerful thing and
that's why I think this will be his
greatest Legacy there will always be
children watching those movies you know
like Woody and Buzz Tom's got a forever
friend and wife Rita
Wilson
we married the right people that's right
I knew something was cooking there uh
right from the from the very beginning
so uh Cindy what uh what else do you do
oh well like Henry said in his tape the
usual stuff Tom and Rita first met in
1981 on the set of Tom Sitcom Bosom
Buddies but it turns out Tom had his
eyes on her long before that I did an
episode of The Brady butt tell me one
two tell me who are
the Bears three four tells me who's
going to score the Bears I was I was
watching on a Friday night where this
cheerleader was so cute she knocked me
out and then I married her et sat down
with Tom just days before he and Rita
tied the knot in 1988 probably be the
same kind of husband as I was a
boyfriend and I thought I was a pretty
good boyfriend so I guess I make a
pretty good husband Tom and Rita have
gone on to partner as producers too
bringing eight projects to audiences
their big biggest surprise Hit My Big
Fat Greek Wedding as the daughter of
Greek immigrant Rita couldn't resist
when are you and time going to get
married you have two more weeks and then
get rid of
him I'm even better than a a Greek boy
cuz I'm a non-greek who had the good
sense to marry a Greek I think what
Tom's living out is that he actually
picked up a table in his mouth and
danced around with it actually it was
chair I did pick up a chair with my
teeth it was a table was it a table yes
it was that's how much fun we were
having cu
the couple has supported each other
through sickness and in health in 2015
Rita was diagnosed with breast cancer
and underwent a double myectomy I would
say that we got closer if it's even
possible to say that today she's
cancer-free and in April Tom and Rita
celebrated their 35th wedding
anniversary I'm totally the luckiest one
in the world and everybody should be so
lucky with their lover today the Hanks
are family of six all four of Tom's kids
are nepo babies including Elizabeth and
Colin from his first marriage from an
early age they were dad Shadows on set
would you ever want your kids to be
actors if they want to go off and and
and try to be better than their old man
that'd be
[Music]
fine Elizabeth who's now a 41-year-old
rider was the first to for a into the
family business making a cameo in 1994's
Forest Gump Otto it was your father's
name you remember
youngest son Truman made his film debut
in the 2022 tearjerker a man called Otto
playing a younger version of his dad the
director wanted Truman in the movie was
really like adamant that he wanted
somebody that looked like Tom right and
so he saw a picture of him and it was
like that guy we do resemble each other
a
lot so Tom Hanks is your dad yeah it's
not that big of a deal okay I want some
answers 46-year-old Colin got his first
major role in the Sci-Fi series Roswell
in 1999 now he's an Emy nominated actor
with over five dozen credits to his name
I was a PA on AA 13 and that was my
first credit when it came time to for me
to actually decide what I was going to
do in college said okay well you know
did a lot of theater in high school and
stuff like that so I'm think I'll give
that a shot worked out thank goodness
Chad might be the most controversial of
the Hanks Clan but after struggles with
addiction he's more than a year sober
for me it took like something drastic
happening like becoming a father for me
to make the change your parents how have
they supported you through your sobriety
by doing just that just just by being
supportive is there a dream project you
would like to have in which the entire
family could collaborate no because I
don't want it to be work I'd like to you
know I'd like to take a I'd like to take
a camping trip across the country all
together
great I've got to go into the control
room and wish everybody good luck have a
good
show it's so nice so Tom Hanks poked fun
at his nice guy image when he hosted
Saturday Night Live back in 1988 yes Tom
officially a member of the show's 10
timers club we leave you with our
favorite Tom SNL moments good night
everybody see ladies and
gentlemen HKS boy you you people must be
getting real sick of me by now now as
you know I started the five timr Club
one of the most exclusive clubs in the
world I'm nowhere near and near Alec
baldwinner Steve Martin excellent corner
for scoping out the be you said a m not
interested in me at all you know um
magazine cover recently called me
America's
dad and I would have preferred sexiest
man alive but I will take it I'm going
to find out what makes Michael Chay tick
what's the deal with
cobwebs I want to
know I never even thought of that man
that's so true let me see
here I got her I got her good thing I
was
here PO is the captain I'm sorry about
that Sully saved everyone just some
accidental tribul y Sully did it
again